so much good stuff planned I am Conan
O'Brien okay this is that's not good
this is the wrong card
[Applause]
why does this keep happening it's
ridiculous let's get it together how
crazy was that last night can we just
vent for a second about that that was
insanity
I watched it today and it was upsetting
I mean I watched it a couple of times
and every time it's so weird yeah yeah
good god
so much to talk about I'm gonna get back
to that screw-up trust me I'll get back
to that but I can't believe that was not
even the only gaffe at last night's
Oscars at last night's Oscars a film
producer who appeared in the in memoriam
montage turns out she's alive
yes she's alive even where she's
scratching loudly at the roof of her
coffin she wants out can you imagine
what they said to her today we got good
news you were on the Oscars they think
you're dead I was wondering why the work
had dried up yeah I don't get calls
anymore there was some bright spots last
night
mahalo Ali became the first Muslim actor
we're not very cool or or as the Trump
Whitehouse reported it Muslim wields
heavy blunt object doing this and they
were like he I don't know they were
worried this was the first year that
Amazon took home Oscars yeah Amazon won
two Oscars for Manchester by the sea
and one for a 4-pack of Norelco
waterproof razor blades
those are good blades how's it going on
president Trump announced that he will
not I repeat not be attending the White
House Correspondents Dinner in April
it's not gonna go yeah it's in April
yeah Trump said he'd like to go but he's
going to be busy not preparing his taxes
probably taxes are for losers you know
new research just came out and it finds
that people who have ADHD literally have
different brains and the rest of us yeah
when told this people with ADHD said I
like pancakes if you have that disorder
my apologies
Spain is trying to boost its national
birthrate by appointing a national sex
czar I would like to COO I'd like to
lodge a complaint because sex are is my
username on tinder
[Applause]
and whatever likes me on tinder
you